ma reine
encore un autre royaume tombe dans ta gloire
miroir miroir sur le mur
qui est le plus beau
de tous
tu es le plus beau
mais il y en a un autre destiné à te surpasser
que veux-tu de moi
et tu régneras
pour toujours
trouve moi quelqu'un qui ne le fait pas  craignez la
forêt sombre pour la traquer d'
accord
si je refuse
qui es-tu pourquoi est la reine une fois que tu
mourras tu devrais savoir que c'est toi qui me
chasse
tu as des yeux chasseur mais tu ne vois pas
elle est destinée à prêter l'obscurité
je  j'aurais dû la tuer quand elle était
enfant
j'ai besoin que son coeur bat
de sang
j'ai vu ce qu'elle voit
je peux la tuer je
donnerai à ce monde misérable la
reine qu'il mérite
lèvres rouges comme du sang
cheveux noirs comme la nuit
apporte moi ton coeur
mon  Chère Chère
Blanche-Neige,
laissez-les venir